Identification. This is Section six recorded with faith.
Bandler and Karen Craig on Friday the twenty seventh of June one thousand nine hundred seventy.
And the tape became a scene a few seconds time. When defied in difficult.
Face do you want to just go on from where you left off last week.
I was talking last week about my life at King's Cross and how I made it is must play and I'll continue from there.
Well. It is true he had an immense. Influence on my life. In a very quiet way.
He was already thought of himself as a Marxist and believed that they issued more equal
or distribution of the wealth of a country for all people. And they were ideas that rather appealed to me.
And I think that had basis for the development of my relationship with him.
And it for me was an extremely rewarding relationship. Mainly because it was all new to me.
I've always wondered why there was this terrible imbalance. With the people of a country where you had.
So much wealth and so much poverty. And not awfully much in between. And. So he.
He talked about this and I found this very and reaching. I did think.
I did know that I fully appreciate fully appreciated what he could give at that it was only after that
but life was good for me I had my by then had moved from doweling street into street and up ahead and attic room there.
But at least it had a little kitchen outside of the main bedroom.
And it was a great atmosphere this was in the heart of. And. People knew each other and people helped each other.
And my landlord was a man who who was Finnish.
And he was a slum landlord he masters and twenty or thirty slum houses in woman who and about my.
I'm not sure that my have been some in Paddington but I'm not quite sure about that but he owned a lot
and he was really a slum lion note.
But I had good politics and his wife
and I became very friendly they lived in a little street called how much street just leading off for street
and it was such a slum I can't describe what it looked in themselves. His main interest was in Masonry.
So cross the road in one of his many many houses he got her sort of finish so want to get in
and tenants were free to go. Which I used.
And it was fun to hear we were all poor and we all had each other great community spirit. And we used to.
And then we'd all my coffee and. Sit in the street. Out in the street you know you didn't go inside.
On the Greek people board and Sunday night. The Greeks would mean they had fish in it.
And we'd all sit outside while I sang and played. You. Like a good. Yes. Well the instrument similar to the good.
And I'd sing in Greek and as they may indeed they named it all hang or drinking coffee.
Nobody drank wine because wine was priceless. It wasn't that long after the war if you got a bottle of wine.
You know you'd feel like a queen of the earth.
There was a lovely atmosphere there and the landlord and his family would your needed.
They were the most of them were his tenants and I had little the little corner shops
and that was where most of the gossip went on. But there was a feeling of safety physical safety. And not so much.
I'm sure that some of them in or around there would have raped a woman with a flick of an eyebrow.
And I but the women somehow protected each other. We looked after each other. And.
And so I would come down and join in with what was good at whatever was going on.
It was a bit new to him in a way although he'd been Australia for many many many years. He he. He was born in Finland.
But he was brought up in Sweden. And my family too. Very wealthy are.
And he came from really an upper middle class background
and he never talked about it all three match until he touched on.
When I asked him about his childhood and so forth and he laughed
and he said he still had two sisters who were living at that over in Sweden.
And so I said you know if you've got to write to them. He said. I ran away and I didn't go to university here.
I jump to shape and I became a seaman and what you have to ship in Australia and here.
He says you know I'm a bit of a black sheep of the family but I said Oh you must write to your sister.
So he wrote to his two sisters. And then after some months thereafter a parcel.
And it was a pass over to all of him so forth. His parents. His family.
They lived in great comfort tremendous force so. And it was wonderful saying these photographs you know.
It was like a fairy tale did people really sit out on the gauge the like can be waited on by servants for afternoon tea
tables and. So from here was this man living here and. He would come down.
Also on Sunday night with me and it was wonderful because he would also ensure. Hearing.
The Greeks music singing and The Who had the ten hands and then Lou.
Had a right spirit
and nobody would agree even if they if they voted for the Liberal Party they wouldn't be good enough to say.
Everyone that may have acted like they didn't vote Labor they voted for come as party.
And then I was asked if I would go to Billy with Margaret in the Margaret walk a dance group.
And I was very hesitant at first and cows you know you can. And the FE was four hundred fifty pounds three to buy it.
And I didn't have four hundred fifty pounds. So. I had a very dear friend whose name was Margaret you.
Lived very wealthy we did. But she was very progressive very left wing.
She had a husband who was involved in the big steel works very well.
And she was very kind and generous and should take me out to lunch
and we'd go to lunch in the Chelsea which was the place to lunch in Sydney. It was down in the quay. And.
She had taken herself off to Czechoslovakia and she.
Fell in love with the place and was absolutely convinced that they had a world where.
And she believed that she was very generous to the communists in Australia with her money. Anyhow.
She took me to lunch one day here and she said I hear you've been asked to go to.
Billion with the market for credit and screw and child you must go which he said
and I said Harker for it she said yes you can. And she said Come I'm certain. And we'll talk a little more about it.
So I went back and Len Fox came with me and we went to Margaret who lived in the are every new in her room.
Where I guess that's where my dressmaker lives now Mark mentions opposite. After all it is and.
And she said look you simply must go and she got up and she went to a beautiful and take this
and wrote the check for four hundred fifty pounds and said he you are my child
and what you will need is not a lot of crying. But you must you cannot go to Europe with it.
You must have it and she went to her wardrobe. And she brought up this beautiful.
Wish I could think of the name of the brand the very famous Scottish coat
and for many years it was again only thing that wealthy people around Sydney in the winter beautifully tailored.
Cotton and I am of the cloth. But anyhow she said and you could wrap it up a new ball and.
Use it for a pillar and it won't have a crease in the morning. Little she knew that I would put it to the test.
So anyhow I went home with a checking account. And you know I was getting that you know you needed more than your fair.
And had a little bank account I didn't have much. And Karl said to me that.
Every fortnight you go to such and such a place and they will pay you know Lance.
And for the whole eleven months I was there he kept it.
And I pounce a fortnight would come and there was a lot of money. A lot of money. I found myself.
Lending to other strains who'd gone broke. So. The day came.
And I packed and I packed very sensibly because I knew is that we would be staying in which was.
A little while and we'd be staying about four days in Bombay. So I made sure I took some nice loose cool copy.
Things about my coat and. Like a couple of slacks.
I only had one suitcase and I made sure I would only carry one suitcase and my new hand they showed their strength
and it was very solidly that. So. The campaign to get Australians to go to this cultural festival. In the ruins of.
Began to spread throughout Australia. And.
Ask who initiated it that will be known to me at the time I'm sure that it was east.
The East German capital which was communist together with the Australian Communist Party. But it was in my direction.
Absolutely. We had a Methodist past and we had people from the Anglican Church and to this church.
We had trade unionists who didn't belong to.
I think they probably well I might have been Labor Party people there was a big contingent.
From the Labor Party in fact.
And also Communist Party members but it seemed to me all along that they were controlling things. Well you should care.
This was a thing to happen to me I was going on a brand new Italian food from Sydney to Naples who let the plot he
think. Listen. MAURICE.
And of course it was in the middle of the Cold War and you cross and forget that Menzies at that time.
Had was campaigning for his party was campaigning for the nineteen fifty one referendum to ban the Communist Party.
So you can imagine.
That things were pretty bloody tense in this country and I'll talk later about that terrible period of the Cold War.
That the day actually. Got a taxi called the taxi and I just want to come back to my life with it lasted.
For so many years I never we never lived together I always had my own room.
But I would call him to his unit which was considered quite power. I have to work every day. And he would have this.
And we turned. And we would have he would prepare a marvelous dinner.
And where he got the while but there was almost a bottle of red. I never fainted alcohol particularly bad.
Somehow I think you know we'd have dinner by candlelight and there would be perhaps lovely results
and he would grind the meat himself to make sure it didn't have certain what was kind of. And.
I do always battle for myself. No one ever looked after me.
Shore walk over now it's very kind to me but it was a kindness that was on the surface as it were.
But here was a kindness that had a great day. It was just beautiful. And as the years went by.
He would have cut his right hand off to do for me if I said so and I had to.
And one night here that night he sort of had a special and it was this little box
and you know it was a beautiful bracelet started with. I still weird and it's now fifty one years old. I still wear.
The watch that he gave me which is now in its fiftieth year and it goes beautifully. So.
Although many were that he left very deep impressions on my life I did know what would have happened had I never met.
And why you from. Maybe I just would have continued going like that and looking after him when he became an old man.
But he died only three years ago. I feel now. Terribly sad for me but I can say that he had.
I was able to help him in his old age he was older than me fifteen years older than me and I was able to help him
when he became ill when he didn't have a house obviously able to get him a beautiful unit and.
Because he couldn't live in the place he had he couldn't managers and there was a woman whom I knew went a very down
and looked after him and took care of him
and he actually bought her car for her if she could take her for a drive sounds very exceptional person fare hikes.
Very exceptional in every way I well come back to the trip to Bill in. I went off. And I went down to the.
Being fair world with a bad idea and had failed.
The wife of the author William had for help and her sister Margaret Fulton. Did I show you that. Photographs. And Card.
And I was very impressed with this ship. It was posh beautiful that all the delegates had to sleep in dormitories.
There was a very installment three and a women's dormitory
and I was asked to go into the dormitory with all the women of course. And we slept in bags.
Well I had little slept in the dormitory because it was hot
and I would go up on deck with my sleeping bag like so many others do you know and sleep on the dick you know and.
But the food was one of the Easy. Breakfasts fantastic lunches and dinners you know octopus.
Small fishes cooked beautifully. Great pestis. And he were ninety one of us. Well we've called in Fremantle.
And by then I had already made some very famous writers in Australia and among them.
Katherine Susan and Pritchard and she came down on the boat to say goodbye.
Where in her beautiful brown velvet jacket and the cream rose in the lower pale.
And somewhere I have a photograph of it but after. It has failed. Well. Then we set off for Columbus.
Is it called Colombo the capital of us or Lanka. Doesn't matter anyhow. And there we were met by the Buddhists.
They knew we were coming. And I said they knew. We were carrying to a festival for peace between the West and the east.
And they came to told us that that they expected us to go to a meeting for peace in the city town hall.
And so the greatest number of us.
Delegation went I think some of Black's went off to look for other things but we weren't.
Perhaps it was of wonderful right here sitting. In this huge turn. Where the Buddhists. And you.
I just looked at a sea of hit. And golden groups. And these people were for peace.
And I thought back in Australia we can't even hire who. To hold meetings for peace. To the peace movement.
Look at this isn't this wonderful.
And they asked some of us to speak in the name of peace
and we were welcomed very warmly by a man who also in the meeting and he was a member of the single least parliament
and his name was Peter. Kinnaman. Marvelous looking man very handsome and. Very forthright.
And very determined that world peace should continue. You see the war had only just ended.
And so we had wonderful meeting. And I felt very very here because.
Here in Australia there was only one who we could really use
and that was that number eighty one eighty eight your street was.
And here we were going into countries that were shouting peace world peace from the rooftops.
Just delegation of ninety one people did it cover all areas of what.
What what kind of people other than the maggot or could dance group in the delegation.
The delegation consisted of artists singers musicians of several years since it was a cultural festival you see trade
unionists and I joined Margaret's dance group these great big miners and war feasts and.
They were you know a very good player that had to do with the lending of the whites in Australia in the treatment of
the complex and the killing of the Aboriginal people.
And that was part of the reason why I went because I was in that particular play. And there were church people.
And church people for priests who were having a tough time in Australia. You know.
They were being blacklisted by the government and. They were able to meet up with church people in other countries.
And I thought that was very worthwhile. It wasn't using delegation and I'm using. Ninety one of us.
But I missed a bit and I'm not. Remember to say that today from Fremantle.
I had become rather friendly with the woman who had the bank. About me I was on the bottom back and she was on the top.
And we were about to have a me early evening meal. And we thought we'd have a share. So there was a long arm I panic.
And I said I'll get Musharraf. And she said Marcia aren't and she came back into the dormitory.
And we all know why what we did was push their suitcases under the bottom bunk because space was very precious.
And I was a rich fortunate because I had spent many days in my life camping and knowing how to economize with space
and always knowing how. I've been in the land.
I mean you had to consider others and you always made sure you left a share of the plane and small things like that
and you didn't spread yourself so travelling with so many women in the storm. It was no problem at all.
Anyhow and no one had her. And she came back and bed to pull her suitcase from under my bag and their hands.
Begging her not to scream. But she did. We had a stowaway from Fremantle.
Chose Our bank to get around that and there were no more.
Stacked legged squatting to pull a suitcase out of the man's face comes up between her legs. Well you know I went like.
I can't remember where I think it was put off here but. Columbus. I think. If I remember correctly.
Anyhow we then left Colombo we went over to. Useful experience and. So they had for a big meeting.
For Peace and Freedom. Peace and Freedom. Now the end of the first quarter it was wonderful just wonderful.
We spent four days there we lived on the ship and we came and went. I've never seen poverty like that ever ever ever.
And the Indian trade union people. Took us out of town to where they lived.
And in the streets of the people to take the children with perhaps minus and a leg so they'd make.
Be a more effective big but when we went to the trade union. Community. I remember very clearly.
I dropped some money out of my pocket and the child picked it up and gave it.
But the most unbelievable poverty such as I can't describe it.